لاجل هؤلاء تغامر بحياتها كل صباح للوصول
الى الصف تقطع جميله وبخوف مسافات لا
يحجبها شيء عن قناص المليشيات هي واحده
اذن من عشرات المتطوعات التي خذنا مغامرات
يوميه مع اسلحه الحوثيين من اجل تعليم
الطلبه في المدارس الواقعه بالقرب من خطوط
تماسي الحرب شرقي تعز احنا ساكنين في
منطقه الارجان في منطقه خط نار
وخد تماس احيانا عندما تحدث هناك مواجهات
تحدث صعوبه فنضطر ان نمشي بين الممرات
الامنه حتى نصل الى المدرسه
بناء الخيريه التي طبعا السنه الاولى
جابوا لنا مدته ثلاثه شهور اما السنه هذه
يعني مجرد في تنسيق ومدري عاد يعني الى
الان في تنسيق بس اما من بدايه الحرب الى
الان يعني ما فيش اي حافز بمبال رمزيه لا
تصل الى 40 دولارا في الشهر يقدمنا على
تلقين مئات التلاميذ دروسهم التعليميه في
المدرسه هذه التي عزف عنها المعلمون نتيجه
الحرب فاقطع الرواتب وسقوط عشرات المعلمين
والطلب بين قتيل وجريح بالقنص والقصف
الحوثي في منطقه صاله شرقا اثر كثيرا على
العمليه التعليميه فيها
ثبت الشلال والجعشاء لن نستطيع ان نبقى في
المدرسه بسببها عمليه القنص التي تتملي
الطلاب المدرسين وراحوا طلاب كثير قنصه
ومدرسين استشهد المدرسين لنا من ضمن
نتيجه همم وجود المنطقه في خط التماس
التسرب كثير من الطلاب وخسرنا الفتيات
للمدرسه بخوف لما نجينا دروس داخل
الضغط الان احنا نطلع قبل الخوف ولما ندرس
نكون همم خائفين لما نجزي عك من البسين
للمدرسه الثانيه ولما يوقع خمسه مدته كذا
يا خاله المدرسه لما يقولوا لي امورنا
متتاليه
الرصاص يتخذ المعلم مدرسه عمر بن عبد
العزيز من هذا المنزل مكان لتعليم الطلاب
بعد ان وضعت المليشات مدرستهم تحت نيرانها
وضع ماساوي يجسد واقع التعليم في المدارس
القريبه من خطوط المواجهه كل شيء في هذه
المنطقه صار مهددا بالخطر نتيجه الحرب
الحوثيه فهذه المدرسه التي تحوي اكثر من
600 طالب وطالبه تقابلها قناصات حوثيه
متمركزه على تمام تترصد حياتهم كل يوم فهم
يتلقون دروسهم التعليميه بخطر دائما سعيد
العربيه من مديريه صاله شرقي تعز